welcome everybody to part nine of the
neural networks from scratch
series in this part we're going to be
introducing the concept of optimization
why it's hard and then we're going to be
introducing the calculus that we'll be
using to overcome this challenge for the
following code you can feel free to
write it out if you want by pausing the
video
but it won't be necessary so you can
just sit back and watch
for this we're going to be using a
simpler data set to start which is
nearly solvable with just some vertical
lines and then later in the video we'll
get back to our spiral data set for
solving this with a neural network we
know that we can adjust weights and
biases
and that the weights and biases impact
things in different
ways but the question is how do we
adjust these so as to improve our model
which in our case means to decrease the
loss
doing this successfully would almost
certainly require us to have some sort
of idea of what
adjusting each of these parameters
individually
might do let's get some intuition of the
complexity of this
problem in an effort to avoid the
calculus
you might wonder what about just
randomly searching or some
halfway intelligent random search
so we'll make a model define the loss
and set some variables to remember our
lowest found loss
and the weights and biases that got us
to that point then we'll go through 100
000 iterations randomly choosing
combinations of weights and biases for
both
hidden layers as a reminder
np.random.randn will produce a standard
normal distribution of values for
whatever shape you pass in the
parameters
so in this case if we just look at
np.random.randomn with parameters 2
comma 3 we get a 2
by 3 array of random values and a
standard normal distribution
we'll continue this for each of the
layer weights and biases
each time you run the random.random
function you get varying results so this
is how we'll somewhat randomly hunt
for weight and bias combinations with
this we'll do a forward pass
calculate the loss and then if that loss
is less than the previously lowest
seen loss we'll update our best weights
and biases along with updating our
lowest seen loss
if we run this we will indeed see that
the loss did decline
some but only just barely value-wise
and accuracy does not improve at all so
what could we do instead
we see that randomly searching for
weight and bias combinations
is probably going to take far too long
again the problem that we're trying to
solve here
is an extremely simple problem this
should be nearly instantly solvable
so randomly searching for weight and
bias combinations
is just going to be unacceptable on any
decent
problem maybe rather than randomly
searching for totally new combinations
every single time
we could instead make random tweaks to
the
current best known weights and biases
all we have to change to do this is
change the assignment
to instead being a plus equals
if this adjustment decreases loss then
we'll keep it and we'll continue to try
adjustments from this new point
otherwise the weights and biases stay
exactly where they were before
now when we run with this concept we can
see that we've actually come up with an
okay solution for this problem
we see continued progress for quite a
while and we end with about 0.17 loss
in 93 accuracy so again all we did here
was rather than just randomly picking
combinations of weights and biases
we just randomly tweaked from the last
best known
combination of weights and biases for
the lowest loss value
so have we found a simpler way of doing
optimization
of neural networks is calculus not
required at all
well remember that we're using that more
basic
vertical data set and that this data set
could be easily solved with just some
perfectly vertical lines and this would
probably indeed get you
93 about percent accuracy so this is
really just a data set that we
don't even need deep learning at all to
solve so now let's change from the
vertical data set back to the
spiral data set this data set still has
clear and obvious classes but
is not solvable by just some vertical
lines we need
a non-linear solution here
with the semi-random logical-ish
tweaking from the best weights and
biases code that we used before
we can run this and see that the outcome
while it does learn
is still a loss that's greater than 1.0
and an accuracy that floats around
40 percent it's of course still possible
that we could continue tweaking the
logic that we're using here for
semi-random optimization but
even this spiral data set is actually a
very basic data set for neural networks
and the complexity of a model required
to learn this would be a pretty small
model
but the problem with randomly searching
is the search space
even if it's a very small model the
search space is still theoretically
infinite so this is still a huge problem
with random search
another issue here is that we're
treating each of the weights and biases
identically when it's likely that
certain weights and certain biases
might be more influential and impactful
than others
also in the end it's likely we reached
what's known as a local minimum
this is a concept we'll talk more on
later but definitely going to continue
being a problem we would have to add
some further logic to help us get out of
this
it turns out that hard problems are hard
to solve and this is why we turn to
calculus which can help us to
intelligently navigate to a solution the
first step towards this navigation
is understanding the impact of a
variable on some function
in our case that's going to be the
impact of the weights and the biases
on the loss per each sample since
samples too can impact the model
differently while the loss function
is a function that we apply to a model's
output not the weights and biases the
weights and biases are directly
influencing that model's output
so it's really the impact of the weights
and biases
on the loss function that we're
interested in
now let's start with a simple function
to understand what we mean by
impact this function takes an input x
and multiplies it by two now let's add
some code to visualize this and we'll
create some inputs
x using python's range and then y will
be the output we can also graph this to
get an idea for what it looks like
so with f of x equals 2x or y
equals 2x what's the impact of x
on y in this case it should be fairly
obvious
it's 2 y will always be double whatever
x
is another way to describe this impact
in the case of a linear function like
this
is the slope which is defined as the
change in y
over the change in x or delta y over
delta x
with a linear function we can calculate
the slope from any two points
let's say x equals zero and x equals one
so that means point one would be two x
or two times zero so y would be zero
for point two that would also be two x
or two times one
so y would be two the delta for y in
this case
is from zero to two so that's two the
delta for x
is from zero to one so it's one so the
slope is two divided by one
meaning the slope is 2.
in python we can calculate this by
indexing y at index
1 minus y at the index of 0 dividing
that
by x at the index of 1 minus x at the
index
of zero giving us again the same answer
the slope is two
but what happens when we have a
non-linear function like
two x squared which makes a graph like
this
depending on which two points that we
use the calculation for the slope
is going to vary so how do we measure
the
impact that x has on y in the case of a
non-linear function like this
calculus proposes that we use the slope
of the tangent line
the tangent line is the quote-unquote
instantaneous slope
between two points that are
quote-unquote infinitely close
on a curve this instantaneous slope
is also the derivative and it should be
noted that this can only be done
on a continuous curve so no sharp
corners or anything like that at least
at the moment we have no idea how to get
these two
infinitely close points on a curve but
we could approximate this by simply
adding a
very small delta from some sample point
let's imagine that we'll use a delta of
0.0001
this means that 0.1 would be 1 and .2
will be one plus that tiny delta now
we'll calculate the slope between these
two very close points which gives us an
approximate derivative
of about four we'll soon learn that the
actual derivative for two x squared at
x equals one is indeed exactly 4. the
small difference here
is because we're using an approximation
technique this is what's known as
numerical differentiation
and it produces the numerical derivative
it's a solution where we just calculate
the derivative
which is the tangent line's slope by
using two points that are infinitely or
at least in our case sufficiently
close the further away the two points
are for this calculation on a curve
the larger the inaccuracy is likely to
be so this is why we want to use two
extremely close points
to help with visualizing this in python
we'll modify our code slightly so that
our graph is created with much smaller
steps at a time creating a smoother
curve finally for us to calculate this
line we need one more element
the y-intercept or the b in the equation
for a line which is y equals
mx plus b the slope of a line is handled
in the mx part
and for now we're just saying the slope
m is 1
for example but we also need to know how
to calculate the b variable if we want
to visualize things
since the equation for a line is y
equals mx plus b
if we already know y and m but we want
to solve for b
we can use basic algebra to say b equals
y
minus mx or using our code's variable
names
b equals y2 minus the approximate
derivative
times x2 so the derivative is the slope
applying this to our existing code we
can now calculate and draw a section of
that tangent line
which you can see as a green line on the
graph on the right
taking this a step further we can add a
list of colors move up the approximate
tangent line
function and add the approximate
derivative and b
as parameters then we'll create a loop
of five iterations
with a for i in range five tabbing over
the calculating and graphing code
we'll then replace x1 to be whatever i
is
then we're going to add a scatter so we
can mark each point that we'll be doing
this calculation of numerical
differentiation with a dot
colored uniquely for that specific point
and then finally we'll be modifying our
plot function to
update with the new parameters for that
approximate tangent line function
and we'll be adding colors
we can then run this calculating the
tangent lines and the slopes
of those tangent lines for each point
along the way using numerical
differentiation
so again what's the point of all this in
order to
intelligently know how to adjust
parameters in a function to make some
desired change
we need to be able to have some way of
calculating the impact of those
parameters on the output of the function
now a slight issue for us is that the
actual function
in a neural network is not so simple as
having a single variable
oftentimes we're attempting to adjust
millions or more
parameters calculating derivatives using
numerical differentiation
would require multiple forward passes
for a single weight
or bias adjustment per sample
this is because for each sample
we'll do a forward pass calculating the
loss at the end
then for each weight and bias
individually
one at a time we'll add that small delta
do another forward pass
calculating the loss again then we'd
revert that parameter back to the
original
state choose a new one add the delta
repeat the forward pass
and continue this for every single
weight and bias
in the network note that here we're only
displaying the deltas
and passes for each weight but this
would also be required for each
individual bias too
and again we need to be doing this
process not only for every single weight
and bias
individually but we need to be doing all
of that
per each sample this would still most
likely be a
faster and more successful approach than
doing things randomly
but we can still do a little better
we're definitely on the right track with
derivatives but using numerical
derivatives in this way would be similar
to brute forcing the problem or
something like that
it would work but it would be slower
than ideal
for multivariate functions instead of
doing something like multiple forward
passes for our neural network
we can use partial derivatives which are
indeed coming up but first we need to
cover the analytical derivative which is
the subject of the next tutorial
as you may be aware if you are enjoying
the content and want another medium to
absorb the material with you can check
out the neural networks from scratchbook
which is fully complete for making
optimizing and testing both
classification and regression neural
networks
you can get the ebook hardcover or
softcover at nnfs.io
we've now sold over 10 000 copies at the
time of this recording which is
pretty staggering thank you to all of
you who have chosen to spend your time
and or money on learning this content
and i will see you all in the next video
you